[Music]
[Music]
today on sick to football it is NFC
South time we're gonna be breaking down
the drafts grading those drafts picking
a division winner it's gonna be a grand
old time this might be the best division
in football maybe a little sneaky but
we're gonna get you caught up on what
these teams did not know and Connor
Rogers where it's raining in Hoboken so
you'll probably hear a thunder storm
that puts me to sleep so flee it doesn't
during the show hopefully we don't
either boys we've been teasing it for a
couple of days and we have some big news
to break right here off the top of the
show this week will be the last week of
stick to football for a couple of months
we are going on vacation
ten years of bleacher report I have
never taken a summer off as we get into
year three of the podcast we want to
take a break a little bit of appalls
reimagine the show so Mather May 14th
excuse me will be the last stick to
football until we're looking at maybe
mid-july guys maybe late July depending
on what happens with the pandemic what
happens with sports schedules we are
excited about this we know some of you
will not be we are gonna take that break
when we come back we want your input
though what is the show gonna look like
what do you like what do you not like
what do you want more of what do you
want less of so coming back in July I
know I am personally excited to be able
to take a step back Connor we've been
doing this show for three years mellow
you've been with this for about two and
a half we now get a chance to actually
stop and think about what we want stick
to football to actually be and then we
get to put that into effect next I'm
excited about it because my whole career
choices have been worked around not
working in the summertime so I'm glad I
can finally get you guys on more with
that to teach your schedule I think
there's a lot of good that can come out
of it I mean number one us being
refreshed and ready to go will be really
really exciting if you've listened to
this show during the long summers we're
all rotating and trying to figure out
how and when and if we can take
vacations and that puts a lot of
pressure obviously on us and we've had
no problem you know pulling through
through those times but it'll be nice
for that but more importantly we've
heard your complaints about the show
length we totally understand we want to
come back and make stick to football the
best product it can be and that's
include remaining as a show you can
watch in the app remaining as a show you
can watch on YouTube but not just 20
minutes not just 25 minutes not just 30
minutes back to an hour back to an hour
plus player interviews obviously a lot
of different fun things that we bring to
the table top fives all of that kind of
stuff
answering more of your draft on draft
questions so when sick to football does
return in July it's gonna be returning
with the bang and I think that's
something that everybody can be excited
about and it's not like we're going
anywhere we will still be on Twitter we
will be in the bleep or app so if you
start to miss us
you can still hate tweet us we will be
there nothing's changing as far as that
goes all right still hey Dave gentlemen
so don't worry Giants yes nothing will
change
I might just not be a Niners fan when we
come back officially all right let's
jump into this though we have some teams
to break down the New Orleans Saints
guys only four picks in the 2020 NFL
Draft but I believe they made a big
impact with these Melo lead us off buddy
where do you have this team graded I
can't believe they only had four picks
in this draft but I really think they
hit it with every single one of them
I'll start with the big guy up front
Caesar Ruiz out of Michigan he's listed
as a sinner
I think he's gonna play a lot of guard
this year as well and you got to protect
Drew Brees I like this move I like that
they have a veteran quarterback and they
say let's go protect this guy with one
of the best interior offensive line
Knight the best interior offensive
lineman in this class even if he plays
guard you need to get Alvin Kamara going
in the running game so that he can get
going in the passing game as well I
think Cesar Ruiz is the guy who comes in
and fixes that problem immediately I
really like this class even despite
having four picks I'm still gonna give
this a b-plus
I really like what the Saints did and I
really like the players that they picked
up yeah the Saints somehow went out and
got really instant impact kind of guys
and with four picks it's hard to get an
A it's nearly impossible but when you
look at this group the impact they can
get from those two guys that I have in
my top 30 Ruiz and Vaughn I gave this
group of B I think that they got a
productive offensive starter right away
in Ruiz who is plug and play and like
Melo said guard and center that matters
especially as you move on from a veteran
and Larry Warford so when you look at
the defensive side of the ball and Zach
Baum this would do it all backer
for the middle of your defense he's
somebody that has shown he can rush the
passer he's somebody that's made plays
against the run and he's athletic enough
to help out in coverage and I think for
the Saints they have someone that could
do that in tomorrow Davis he's getting a
little older now you get another piece
like that in Zach Bowen I think this is
really really exciting so Adam Troutman
I had him as an early day three tight
end and that's based essentially right
around where they took him Tommy Stevens
I'm curious to see how they use him
because now you have a lot of
quarterbacks in one room but I think
they'll have some kind of plan for him
so this was a B for me a very good draft
for the Saints considering they only
made four selections yeah that's the big
takeaway here only four picks it's hard
to make a team that they have superbowl
aspirations this is it for Drew Brees
after this year he's going to NBC to
call Notre Dame football games this is
the Last Dance for Drew Brees did they
do enough to load up the roster to keep
that Super Bowl window open in like I
said a very tough division that now has
Tom Brady now has Teddy Bridgewater
starting for the Carolina Panthers I
gave this a b-minus and I think the
player here the only player left that
you guys didn't mention is Adam trot
minute tight in out of Dayton he was my
number two tight end in the 2020 draft
class I know the level of competition
was not great but anytime he leveled up
and played better defenses god this
looks like a high school field any time
he did that our man showed up and I like
Adam Trotman I said in my notes in the
scouting report there's a little George
kettle to his game he'll play dirty
he'll play nasty hopefully physical
but you see his ability to run seam
routes he's athletic moving down the
field I do not think he's gonna take
Jared Cook's job anytime soon but now
you can work some too tight in sets
don't forget they added Emmanuel Sanders
you get a healthy Alvin Kamara in the
backfield I think this team is going to
be one of the best in the NFL again in
2020 as soon as we see the Saints back
on the field now guys the Atlanta
Falcons finished second in this division
last year in 2019 they use two
first-round picks on the offensive line
they come back this year with a focus on
defense and adding a couple more weapons
for Matt Ryan Melo start us off buddy
what's your grade and how did you like
really a draft that focused a lot on the
trenches yeah I like this draft I think
they did an okay job I'm gonna give it a
B
I think that they reached a little bit
for some of these guys you look at AJ
Terrell at pic 16 that's not where I had
him slotted but I did think he would go
in the first round and I think this was
a weird draft where they probably did a
lot of work to try to move up and get a
guy like chase young or get a Jeff Okuda
they didn't do a whole lot of work on
let's trade back and try to get AJ
Terrell later in this draft so a weird
raft with Corona going on not being able
to trade and communicate with your
partner so much so I like the AJ Terrell
pic I think that he's a guy who fits
very well in this defense who can be
that lengthy corner who can come in do
the cover three stuff that you need to
and you have to be able to stop the pass
to win this division so I like this this
draft form specifically AJ Terrell I'm
gonna give him a B for their draft class
not my favorite draft here for the
Falcons I was a little harsh and gave
this one a C - I thought Terrell was a
second round player and has a lot of
developing to do Marland Davidson I had
him in the second round I think he'll be
a fine starter I like Matt Hennessy in
the third round at that point I think he
could be an average starting center was
not a fan of any of the day three picks
to be honest with you I thought they
took Mike hell Walker a little early
drafted a punter and once again I think
what this comes down to why I was so
harsh and gave this a c-minus is because
when you look at Terrell here guys
I thought they passed on a lot of good
players I thought Caleb on Chaisson was
somebody that could have made a way
bigger impact for this defense I thought
yes they desperately needed a corner but
if you are gonna reach on Terrell I'd
rather just trade one of those day two
selections and try to go up for somebody
like CJ Henderson I would have taken
Jeff Gladney instead of AJ Terrell so
when I looked at this once again I would
have taken C D lamb instead of AJ
Terrell so for the Falcons listen it's
not a horrible draft I think two of
these guys will develop into long term
starters I just don't see big-time
impact at all in a division where you
got to constantly be taking haymaker
swings this to me felt like a team that
had put all their eggs in the CJ
Henderson basket and when he went nine
overall the Jacksonville they were like
oh oh what do we do now and they just
took the next best corner on their board
instead of the next best player on their
board
which probably would have been a CD lamb
okay LaVon chase on there were options
there maybe even one of the safeties
even though we didn't see a run on that
position happen so that to me felt a
little bit cute in my notes that night I
wrote down there a lot a lot of reaches
with these picks they I mean even I
thought Matt Hennessy that was a good
value but like Marlin Davidson for that
defense playing next to Grady Jarrett
that's absolutely gonna help him but as
you said Connor those day three picks a
lot of reaches and when you're
first-round pick is a reach that's a
little concerning for me let's go back
to Marlin Davidson when we first started
scouting this guy it was like oh this is
an edge rusher and he's like 275 pounds
then you see him at the Senior Bowl
person and you're like no no my man had
some sandwiches he's a nose tackle he's
a defensive tackle and he showed up in
Mobile one day I practiced before he
hurt his ankle in that one day he put
himself into a top 50 player
conversation I wasn't drafted there but
Marlin Davidson next to Grady Jarrett
with the speed on the edge of Technic
inle and Dante Fowler gives them
something that could be very very
special in the middle we know they have
speed at linebacker hopefully you guys
like Johnny Neal can develop a safety
I thought AJ Trobe was a little bit of a
reach that's why I gave this one a C+
it's a good roster we know how explosive
they can be on offense but the defense
is going to have to step up don't forget
guys send your draft on draft questions
and you can leave them right here in the
comment section below if you're
listening to the podcast version of this
still soon those wrapped on draft
questions just hashtag them on Twitter
we're gonna check those out
we'll get them into the shows on
Wednesday or Thursday afternoon now
today's show is sponsored by Playstation
home to MLB the show the official game
of people everywhere who just need a
break from the world for a few hours
with jaw-dropping graphics and more
gameplay than ever
MLB the shows a great reminder of what
outside looks like we know you missed
the crack of the bat the roar the crowd
in the sensation of the Sun on your skin
so PlayStation has you covered with MLB
the show finally baseball you won't want
to leave
at the bottom of the seventh so you can
beat traffic if you're looking for other
escapes PlayStation also offers call of
duty modern warfare because even that is
less stressful than the world today
thank you to PlayStation for sponsoring
stick to football if they could just
capture the like hotdog taste or the
smell of the popcorn it's pretty it's
pretty good like I think that maybe we
branch off when we start to stick to
baseball podcast when this thing's on
high we are gonna have some free time
that's summer now so maybe maybe you
stick to baseball coming to you on
Tuesdays and Fridays not really all
right let's get it to the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers probably no team in the NFL
is more changed from where we saw them a
week 17 to where we'll see them in week
one Tom Brady's in Brock is in the
defense is gonna look a lot different
started today they went offensive tackle
and round one that is boy did they get
an impact at 45 overall oh I loved this
draft guys I mean listen I give this an
A and they got two of my round one
graded players Tristan Worf so I thought
was the second best offensive lineman in
this class and then to get Antoine
Winfield jr. when they did he's going to
be a star under Todd Bowles Todd Bowles
played safety in the NFL he's coached
very very good safeties and most
importantly he's developed safeties over
the years so when you look at that
matchup I think it's absolutely perfect
he shot Vaughn will bring an explosive
element to their offense at the running
back position I think this team did a
phenomenal job
I had Tyler Johnson in the fourth round
they got him in the fifth so I think
he'll even find his way to get some
targets in that offense but when you
look at the impact that a guy like
Antoine Winfield jr. can make for a
defense when he is healthy he is a
turnover machine that's what matters so
much and for the Bucks
they have lacked that kind of presence
in their secondary for a couple of years
now they've taken their swings in the
draft they've tried they've just missed
a little bit and they took a lot of DBS
last year that are still developing but
nobody on the level of Winfield jr. he's
somebody that can come up in the box
make plays in the backfield great
instincts but also really good awareness
and coverage and once again working with
Todd Bowles that is the best thing that
can happen to him so for the Bucks this
is an a all the way
and I think I'm gonna give this one yeah
all right guys I'm gonna give this one a
B I'm sorry I'm gonna go a minus on this
one I really liked their draft like you
were talking about Connor I really like
worse and the fact that he was there for
them and available great pick one of the
best tackles in this class you get
Antoine Winfield jr. who we all loved on
this podcast yes why the hell did you
trade up though you gave up a fourth
round pick to one spot why did you do it
so I'm actually ok with that because
you're securing your guy you're making
sure that the new you believe the Niners
BS that's like you're tired you had to
trade up to make sure they weren't gonna
take a tackle that's why I think they
did it I mean I get you it's like you
never trade up one spots get your guy
Niners must I wanted him to bags right
now okay this is the difference between
an a-plus and an a-minus here I think
though you gave up a valuable pick that
you probably would have nailed because
you did on the rest of your draft I
really like it but I don't understand
why you gave up my fourth round pick
even though you get that seventh round
your back whoo this is an a-minus wrap
it's a very good draft I just don't know
why teams keep doing this with the 49ers
though hey we're gonna trade up and
we're gonna get you guy you better trade
with us so we don't draft him what I
know there was a lot of fear that like
the Denver Broncos would try to jump up
and get a tackle because Guerra bulls
isn't good so I do agree it's it's the
Niners or in people's head about this
hopefully it works better for Tampa than
it did for the Chicago Bears but I do
agree with you guys
Tristan works was the number two tackle
on my board I'm a huge fan of his
athleticism I know there's some you know
thought maybe he's not a left tackle
it's okay Donna Smith will be he could
play on the right side and be very very
good we saw him do that in Iowa no
concerns about that Antoine Winfield jr.
is going to play the honey badger role
for this team River Bruce Arians and
Todd Bowles had the honey badger coming
out of LSU they know how to use a player
like that who can just roam and eat
Beast on offenses I think that's what
we'll see Antoine Winfield jr. - how
about Keyshawn Vaughn fantasy football
players remember this dude's name
deepened drafts because I'm not
convinced Ronald Jones is gonna be able
to hang consistently for an entire
season Keyshawn Vaughn an excellent
receiver out of the backfield and if
this offense is anything like what we
saw in New England they're gonna rotate
backs in here very very often in a I
would thought they did a good job
around 5:00 and getting my guy Tyler
Johnson to play in that slot role I
wouldn't be surprised if he's the number
three receiver on this team now they
have two very good tight ends that
they're gonna have to spread the ball
around to it's three excuse me two and a
half we'll call two and a half tight
ends
but Tyler Johnson's gonna get some looks
here so I have to give this an A+ I
thought they had excellent value the
first two rounds they dominated there
and then they check needs off to build a
roster they can win right now cuz that's
what you're trying to do a Tom Brady
this is not about next year it's about
right now and these are all
plug-and-play type players now how about
the lowly Carolina Panthers a team that
did not take badly enough for a
quarterback they're moving on with Teddy
to gloves at the position Connor take it
away what's your grade format rules new
team I'm okay with signing Teddy but
once again guys I think if you do that
you really need to put an emphasis on
the offensive line and I have not seen
the Panthers do that yet so when you
look at this draft
I gave it a see Derek Brown I know he's
gonna be a good player but did you need
to take a defensive tackle with the top
ten pick that's not necessarily what I'm
convinced of and even if you needed to
do that
because you feel like he was too good to
pass up they didn't address the
offensive line again on day two so this
draft I mean listen Jeremy chin I
thought the hype got a little bit out of
control you two gross mottos to somebody
that can dip it definitely develop in
the front seven I think his pass rush
plan is not fully there but you know
they can coach him up but once again how
much impact are they gonna get out of
this class besides Derek Brown I don't
see it they needed help on run defense
that unit was terrible last year Matt
rule comes in there he's just simply not
going to accept getting run on like that
so they obviously prioritized Brown who
the best part of his game is against the
run and has power against as a pass
rusher but for the Panthers here I just
don't think they've done enough on the
offensive line to let Teddy succeed they
have a ton at wide receiver they have
one of the best running backs in the NFL
they have a young exciting offensive
coordinator I just don't understand this
the strategy of this draft I really
don't understand it I'm gonna give them
a seed they didn't draft a single
offensive player I don't know how you
say that I mean there are some holes
obviously on the offensive line in this
on this team maybe you want to get you
know a backup running back at least
late you have to target some kind of
offense I like what they're building on
the defense I like those two big
defensive tackles and then you're gonna
put the speed rush on the outside with a
you know a Brian burns and a year of
gross tomatoes I really like the way
that he's gonna fit into this defense
you're just you're trusting drupe job
radiate a lot to figure out the
offensive side when you're gonna let the
big guys like this eat on the defensive
side and it's a bold strategy but when
you have that long of a contract I guess
you can start taking risk and say well
look at that 2021 Draft there are some
good offensive talent there but I do
like that gross Tomatoes pick it sassy
for me I wish they would have addressed
the offensive line did a little bit more
on the offensive side I don't love the
Derrick brown pick in the top ten either
I think that that's a position it's very
hard to get your value at in the top ten
so it probably could have traded down
and worked some magic there on the draft
board I'm gonna give this one see I
think you know I'm crazy
I liked this trap a lot and yeah like I
would have loved to see them gone office
but they trade it for Russell looking
and I know moving trait Turner's a big
part of that but now they're set up with
a little more financial flexibility and
you're getting approval left tackle with
the hopes maybe the Greg little can sit
and learn how to do this and be your
starter bubble but they're there Brad I
do feel a little bit like was a reach
but we also knew that pic was gonna
happen so it's like I guess I was kind
of conditioned to it a little numb to
drafting a nose tackle at seven overall
I like to get you to gross modest around
- that was a steal for me maybe the
steal of the draft and then I am a big
Jeremy chin fan I think especially in
this defense where he's gonna play a
little bit of a rover he's gonna play
strong safety he's probably gonna play
some weak side linebacker we've seen the
Carolina Panthers have success with that
which it was Shaq Thompson with a lot of
other players Thomas Davis who were good
athletes so I'm excited about this class
I am am a true love Joe Brady fan I
think they're gonna be able to figure
this out but this division is very tough
so while the Panthers might be better I
don't know if their records gonna be
better they might be one of the teams
fighting for a Trevor Lawrence Justin
fields tre Lance in 2021 even though I
am the biggest Teddy Bridgewater fan of
the world so I gave it a B I like the
draft overall but as you guys said maybe
a little cute going all defense maybe
maybe maybe a little cute right let's
take a look at some grit
iron Heights one of my favorite movies
growing up his kid was that movie se7en
with Brad Pitt
spoiler alert when he opens the box at
the end discuss scary disgusting but
that's not in this episode of river nice
[Music]
you call it the backups Teddy names
he'll I don't throw the footballer
lineup under center I'm not old
fashioned like you you are three years
older than me coach says we have to play
nice with him
I want the both of you on this
everyone's gonna be so confused someone
has taken out starters based on the 7qb
sins greed soft oh this is so comfy that
I'm so hungry for knowledge in the
playoffs gosh it was my first kiss and
then I just what the rush to treat me
the same now that's only six are you nut
job we lost good man is big there don't
you see
no quarterback is greater than the
almighty shield it's a six game injury
you guys only need to win like three
games holding on the offense yeah I
can't wait to see the updated pull it
off the Eagles version well jaylen hurts
Carson wins maybe Jordan loved Aaron
Rodgers who knows you know dak Prescott
is gonna be the green sin that's
everybody thinks just money but I wanna
get paid good Dennis and the guys do you
remember the old MTV Celebrity
Deathmatch they need to do that with
these quarterback battles just throwing
ideas if anybody wants it it's free
let's pick a division winner go around
the horn Melo who is winning the NFC
South it's still the Saints that you
mentioned and they might be one of the
best teams in the NFL you bet your ass
they're one of the best teams in the NFC
I love what they're doing with this team
and how they're building it and Drew
Brees for one more year that's gonna
rally that locker room just say we're
doing one more for Drew and I think it's
gonna work with Sean Payton their Saints
win this division easily no way Saints
are phenomenal I thought what they did
in the draft was very very impressive
you look at their draft Nago maybe they
can get one player it feels like they
got two especially when you can add bond
into the mix on defense so I'll take the
Saints I think the Panthers got a lot
better I think the Bucks are gonna be a
lot of fun to watch this year and very
very competitive the Falcons kind of in
the middle somewhere so New Orleans all
the way yeah I hate to do this but I'm
gonna make it three for three and go
with the Saints as well because I would
say not trying to be cute trying to be
right and that is what I'm doing with
the same sorry you guys left some draft
on draft questions we're gonna answer
three of them too
did the bucks do everything in their
power to maximize a run with Tom Brady I
think you have to say yes there I don't
know what more they could have done
under the loose restrictions of a salary
capital it depicts they had I think they
have open does that Super Bowl window a
little bit yeah I think a lot of people
talked about it early in the offseason
this was a very good team that was maybe
held back a little bit by their
quarterback and then you go out and you
add you know a decent depth running back
a very good offensive lineman and one
hell of a safety I do think they did
everything in their power I think
they've nailed the off season and no
team has done a better job of building
this team up from where they were to
where they are now the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers without a doubt I mean what
else could you ask from them they
convinced Rob Gronkowski to come out of
retirement after getting Tom Brady to
come down south and work with Bruce
Arians you know Todd Bowles wasn't a
great head coach he's a phenomenal
defensive coordinator he really is the
guy can gameplan with the best of them
so I think they have a good staff down
there you know the offense got a lot
better my question with them was the
offensive line and Tristan works to me
was the second best offensive lineman in
the draft they got him all the way at 13
they needed a play making safety they
got that I don't really know what else
they could have done a great job by the
box and they're gonna be must watch TV
this year no I absolutely agree I think
they did a great job of getting those
weapons that we said as we said those
are plug and play players these are not
developmental guys you're not trading up
for Marcus Davenport just like the
Saints did you're taking guys that we
think can step in and play right away my
second question from JP g89 could
Anthony McFarland take over RB 1 the RB
one spot in Pittsburgh within the next
two seasons anthony mcfarland running
back out of maryland can carbon up on
texas longhorns twice i thought it's a
possibility
when you look at this running back room
there's a lot of talent there obviously
everyone wants to see James Connor
perform and be very successful we didn't
last year though so it's gonna be hard
to tell and with little booger mcFarland
the dude can catch the ball out of the
backfield he's added some bulk to his
size I think that there's enough to say
in the next two years could he be RB 1
yeah I think there is enough to say that
I think he could be the most impactful
running back for the Steelers the
question is is the workload
to be there to get that rb1 label we in
the media and fans so desperately chase
the label with running back so I think
with MacFarlane he's gonna add a pass
catching element he's gonna add an
outside run element that ever haven't
seen a ton of with James Connor recently
the question is that Ken his frame holds
up in that kind of role in the NFL but
you don't make a difference yeah that's
why I see him as a complementary guy
like a Dion Lewis type back who exactly
whether it's James Conner or Benny snow
or they like Jalen Samuel however
whoever is the number one guy I think he
fits in and will have an impact but like
Conor said this is it he's five eight
208 pounds to me it doesn't seem like
that doesn't scream Pittsburgh Steeler
running backs do you have Jerome Bettis
Willie Parker okay so I but I think
there's been a lot of transition in that
running back room it seems like you know
going back to you in the drill Bettis
days you think you have your running
back and you're all set and then say
well let's back up guys actually pretty
good too I mean even with lady on Bell
there for a couple years he got his job
as being the number two guy and then
coming in and stealing hooker you threw
Willie Parker out last question don't
forget we'll be back Wednesday with the
AFC West and Thursday with the NFC West
5:00 p.m. Eastern Time breaking those
down his team Mike team that's just
gonna be a lovefest of the Chiefs and
49ers alright last question from Garrett
Greenlee do you think AJ Terrell could
develop a lot faster than an average
first-round corner because he'll play
Julio and Calvin Ridley and practice
every day I think it helps I don't know
that he's going to develop faster
because of it I don't think that Julio
is gonna go full MJ on him and practice
and demand excellence out of him every
rep he's not gonna punch it's definitely
going to help when you have to face
Julio Jones every day of practice you
get to see what one of the best
receivers is going to do you're gonna
learn those tricks of the trade
hopefully Julio can teach him and kind
of coach him up on what he's doing and
what he can look for I don't know that
it's gonna be faster than anybody but he
definitely has an advantage there
maybe not development but definitely
conditioning because he's gonna be
chasing both of those guys down the
field a lot early on in training camp
guys I think when you look at Tyrell one
thing that can
help him I'm excited about the Falcons
front this year you add to Dante Fowler
to the mix yeah obviously have Grady
Jarrett there damn Quinn is somebody
that can coach up a front for a front
seven so I think that'll help him having
a little help with guys getting after
the quarterback yeah I don't know that
it's gonna help them be that looks
better I think you're gonna know if he's
good earlier like your evaluation is
gonna be easier I don't know that the
development necessarily will come faster
or not but I know I like deja TRO a lot
until second half of the nati when my
man got roasted by Jamar Chase who we
will be talking about a ton when we come
back a lot occasion in late July cannot
wait to talk about the 2021 draft class
all right that is our show follow us on
Twitter at stick to football he's at
Melo he's at Connor Jay Rogers I am at
and if they'll dress go don't forget
we'll be back Wednesday 5:00 p.m.
eastern time talking about I think the
Kansas City Chiefs will get mention once
or twice but hey that division looks a
lot better post trap the melon Connors
Matt we'll see you all Wednesday
[Music]
[Music]